حسنًا ، أنا أتحدث إليكم من بلد
يشعر بصراحة تامة بالخروج من
العالم
أو خارج هذا العالم في الوقت الحالي بسبب
مهمته للتواصل
مع الكوكب الأحمر ، وهو مسبار الأمل الفضائي الإماراتي الذي
يحقق مدارًا مع المريخ
منذ وقت قصير
تحققت أول مهمة بين الكواكب في العالم العربي
وهي صفقة كبيرة
، الإمارات العربية المتحدة هي الدولة الخامسة الوحيدة في
التاريخ التي تصل
إلى الكوكب الأحمر ، وقد تحلي بالصبر
بينما قطعت المركبة الفضائية
حوالي 190 مليون كيلومتر
على مدار سبعة أشهر ، تتوهج الإمارات
بفخر بمعالمها.  مضاءة باللون الأحمر
للاحتفال بالوصول إلى الكوكب الأحمر
جيدًا ، أريد أن أجلب
القوة الدافعة
وراء كل هذا سارة الأميري هي
رئيسة وكالة فضاء الإمارات العربية
المتحدة ووزيرة الدولة للتكنولوجيا المتقدمة
التي تبتهج عندما نتواصل معها
من دبي هذه الساعة ، كيف تشعر
سارة
بيكي ، لقد تجاوزت كوكب المريخ في الوقت الحالي ، لقد
كانت
رحلة رائعة لأكثر من ست
سنوات الآن من العمل في هذه المهمة
سلسلة  من تحديات القناة التي أعتقد
أن أكثرها إثارة للأعصاب كانت
آخر 27 دقيقة لا أريد
أن أعيدها
مرة أخرى في حياتي مرة أخرى ، لكننا فعلنا ذلك ، فنحن
حول المريخ لأول مرة
كأمة خامسة
وأمة  أول دولة
عربية صدقوني جيدًا ، ليس عليك أن تعيد
ذلك مرة أخرى لأنه تم إنجازه
وتهنئة الوزير ، هذا أمر
رائع للغاية ، فقط
اشرح ما إذا كنت ستفعل ما تم
تحقيقه للتو من حيث
المهام بين الكواكب
في الوقت الحالي نحن  لدينا أول
قمر صناعي للطقس للمريخ حول المدار
والذي سيمنحنا فهمًا أفضل
لتغير المناخ على
المريخ وأيضًا دور المناخ الذي
يلعبه المناخ في فقدان الغلاف الجوي ،
وهذا هو الأول من نوعه بالنسبة للعالم ، وهذا
هو الأول بالنسبة للعلماء حول  حول
العالم ،
نتطلع حقًا إلى الأمام خلال
الأشهر القليلة المقبلة للوصول إلى النقطة
التي يمكننا من خلالها إصدار البيانات
للجمهور ، ولكن بالنسبة لي كان الأمر الأكثر
إثارة للاهتمام
هو المركبة الفضائية
تم تصميم المرة الأولى لهذه المهمة ،
حيث تم استخدامها في أصعب نقطة لها 27
دقيقة للوصول إلى المدار ، وذهبت
تمامًا وفقًا للنقطة التي يتم التخطيط لها من
خلال الجهد
الدقيق لعدد لا يحصى من الأشخاص ليالٍ بلا نوم
على مدار 5.5 مليون ساعة عمل بالنسبة لنا
للوصول إلى هذه النقطة
أننا اليوم
صُنعنا من قبل علماء إماراتيين ونساء
أعرف الذين عملوا
جنبًا إلى جنب مع
أه زملائهم في أجزاء أخرى من
العالم ولكن ما
مدى أهمية هذا الأمر في هذا
البلد الذي
تحتفل به الإمارات العربية المتحدة اليوم.  اليوبيل الذهبي ،
50 عامًا من القدوم من
بلد لا توجد به
بنية تحتية نسبيًا إلى بلد لديه الآن
مدار حول المريخ
، وهو شرط لمدة 50
عامًا قادمة يتمتع بقاعدة صلبة
والابتكار التكنولوجي العلمي
والإبداع
اليوم نضع علامة  على
قدرات مهندسينا وقدرة دولة
الإمارات العربية المتحدة على نقل
الخبرة وبناءها لبناء قطاعات مبنية بشكل كبير
على التكنولوجيا
كم كانت الأولوية كبيرة
لهذا المشروع سارة كان
هذا المشروع مشروعًا ذا أولوية عالية
لوحظ من قبل القيادة العليا
داخل الدولة
وعلى مدار السنوات التي
عملنا عليها ، قدمنا لهم تح
يثات مباشرة حول المكان الذي قمنا فيه  وصلنا حتى الآن ،
رأينا اليوم حتى قيادة الإمارات
جنبًا إلى جنب مع الفريق
خلال أصعب اللحظات دون
أن نعرف حتى ما هو الناتج
الذي يمثل
أهمية الجيل المستقبلي
الذي أشعر بالامتنان لكوني جزءًا منه  لدفع
عجلة التنمية في دولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة ، شيء
مهم بالنسبة لنا لا يمكننا
التوقف والانتظار ، نحتاج إلى مواصلة
تنويع اقتصادنا ،
نحتاج إلى مواصلة تنويع طريقة
عملنا
يا وزير ، أريدك فقط أن تفكر فيما
إذا كنت ستفكر لمشاهدينا في جميع أنحاء
العالم  كيف وصلت أنت وفريقك إلى هنا اليوم ،
لقد بدأت العمل على هذا البرنامج
في نهاية عام 2013 وكانت
سلسلة من التحديات التي اعتقدنا
أحيانًا
أنها لا يمكن التغلب عليها من خلال التكنولوجيا.
منظور هنيدي
أيضًا من القيام بذلك لأول
مرة لم يكن الأشخاص معتادون على الطريقة التي
كنا نصمم
ونطور بها هذه المهمة ، لم يكن أمامنا سوى ست سنوات لتصميمها وتطويرها ، لم تكن الميزانية التي
كانت لدينا عالية جدًا التي
مررنا بها  الكثير من التحديات التي
مررنا بها في أوقات مختلفة حيث
تعطلت الأشياء عندما لم يكن من المفترض أن
تتعطل ،
كان علينا إصلاحها في الوقت المناسب
لنقل المركبة الفضائية إلى حيث يجب أن تكون اليوم ،
أنا ممتن حقًا
للأداء الاحترافي لـ  المركبة الفضائية ما
جعل هذه
المهمة رائعة بيكي ليس فقط
200 إماراتي كانوا يعملون على هذا ،
بل 450 شخصًا من البعض من
قارات
مختلفة من خلفيات مختلفة من
معتقدات مختلفة ، كان هذا حقًا مسعى
دوليًا وهذا ما يحتاجه العلم ليكون
هذا هو  ما يدور حوله الاستكشاف ،
آمل أن تحصل على قسط من النوم الليلة
لأنني متأكد من أنك على استعداد
للاعتراف
بأنك قضيت بعض الليالي بلا نوم
ولكن سارة إنها  يسعدني استضافتك
شكرا
جزيلا لانضمامك إلينا والتحدث مع
الوزير
هنا وراء هذا المشروع حيث أن
مسبار الأمل الإماراتي الفضائي يحقق المدار مع المريخ
منذ وقت قصير فقط
تهانينا